We've got a pretty good idea which movies
will break the bank at the box office in 2017,
but there's more to the year in movies than
picking blockbusters and super-franchises.
We've gone over the release schedule, taken
a look at the prevailing trends, and come
up with some theories about what's happening
at the cineplex over the next 12 months — and
beyond.
Rey's DNA
There are some bets that seem safer than others
when it comes to Star Wars: Episode VIII.
While it's almost a guarantee that there'll
be at least one of these lines thrown into
the script...
"I gotta bad feeling about this."
...it's less clear which, if any, more throwback
character cameos will come into the mix — or
if any of those parentage issues left lingering
around the new kids on the galactic block
will finally be revealed.
With that in mind, we're predicting Star Wars
fans will learn more about Rey's lineage.
We expect to see her training with Luke, who
seems at least somewhat likely to be her father
— and don't forget, Luke found out who his
dad was in the second installment of the original
trilogy, so that would be good timing.
Logan 2.0
Sorry, Wolverine fanatics, but we're predicting
Logan — at least, as portrayed by Hugh Jackman
— is not long for this world.
Not only has his healing ability been compromised
by the hand of time in Logan, but the movie's
trailer also seem to suggest the story will
serve as a full-length introduction for his
replacement.
Marvel Comics' Laura Kinney, a.k.a. X-23,
is Logan's cloned daughter in the comics — and
she ultimately assumes his mantle after his
death.
Logan seems to be on a suicide mission to
protect her in the trailer — and she's so
cute with those sunglasses, after all — so
we wouldn't be surprised to see him make the
ultimate sacrifice while X-23 comes into play
for The New Mutants.
Especially since that's exactly what happened
in the comics.
Stephen King is king
Of all modern American authors, perhaps none
has had quite as much of an impact on Hollywood
as Stephen King.
His stories have spawned dozens of movie adaptations,
some of which he's liked enough to make cameos
in.
His library has also spawned several TV shows
and miniseries, but until now, some of his
most high-concept stories have remained firmly
shelved.
That changes with The Dark Tower, which many
King fans consider the backbone of the author's
extended story universe.
If its big-screen adaptation does well enough
upon arrival later this year, there's definitely
room for growth in the series.
So prepare for a full-on franchise if the
box office take is right.
And if the upcoming adaptation of King's IT
lands too, you can really get ready to see
filmmakers dive into the King archives for
even more bestsellers that could be turned
into potential franchises.
Sequel setbacks
Go ahead and free up your calendar space on
June 9th now, because there's just no way
World War Z 2 is going to be in theaters that
day as scheduled.
Even several months out, the film still hadn't
even secured a director, and it's not the
only delay that's virtually inevitable this
year.
James Cameron's Avatar 2 release date for
2018 will probably get another nudge back
into 2019, if not further, given the lack
of progress on the production front so far.
Well, that and the fact that Cameron wants
to make his four Avatar sequels all at once.
Meanwhile, don't be surprised if the Jumanji
reboot-slash-sequel gets kicked back again,
too, because it's notoriously had trouble
finding footing — and it wouldn't necessarily
be shocking if Andy Serkis' Jungle Book: Origins
ends up delayed or even scrapped altogether
in the wake of Disney's critical and commercial
success with its own live-action Jungle Book.
"Relax, kid, no need to get worked up, k?"
Galactic expansion
If we've learned anything from the Disney's
Pixar and Marvel mergers, it's that when Disney
gets its white-gloved paws into something
lucrative, the studio's going to take full
and eager advantage.
"One million, two million, three million,
four!"
That's already the case with Disney-Lucasfilm,
which will undoubtedly start rolling out more
Star Wars sequels, prequels, and standalone
stories now that Rogue One has confirmed that
the franchise is viable even outside of the
Luke-Leia-Han Solo story axis.
With the Han Solo prequel on deck for 2018
and Episode 9 scheduled to follow along in
the summer of 2019, we can probably count
on the Star Wars franchise to start looking
more like the MCU, with two-a-year announcements
trickling in for the release schedule.
How that impacts the brand's quality, of course,
remains to be seen.
Fingers crossed.
Go Gamora
Since the superhero world seems ever geared
towards expanding its franchise horizons,
Harley Quinn, Wonder Woman, and Captain Marvel
are all preparing for time in the spotlight.
But there's another character who might be
due for some solo screen time: Gamora from
Guardians of the Galaxy.
Once Volume 2 drops in May, its inevitably
impressive receipts will probably justify
giving some member of the team his or her
own day in the sun, MCU-style.
One could easily argue that Gamora's the ideal
candidate for the job.
Consider her meaty family story with Thanos
and Nebula, her radness outside of being the
object of Star-Lord's affection — not to
mention the fact that she's currently starring
in her own solo comics title.
Gamora will no doubt prove to be key in the
Avengers' fight with Thanos, and if she were
to get a standalone story, it'd mean she could
introduce the badass all-girl warrior group
the Graces.
Her credentials are there, and Zoe Saldana
has a proven record at the box office.
Musicals are in (again)
For all its faults, 2016 did help to usher
in a new generation of movie musicals.
After successful broadcasts for Grease: Live
and Hairspray Live drummed up impressive ratings
on the small screen, La La Land reminded everyone
that there's still a place for this type of
good old-fashioned entertainment in theaters.
The passing of Singin' in the Rain star Debbie
Reynolds may spark a revival of interest in
classic singalong cinema, or even inspire
a studio or two to take a stab at a remake.
And Mary Poppins Returns with Emily Blunt
and Lin-Manuel Miranda should get a boost
thanks to the La La Land appreciation craze.
Hollywood stars, take note: it might be wise
to schedule some singing lessons.
The new kids
Emma Stone will probably be the awards season
sweetheart of 2017, which means someone might
finally get the bright idea to put her and
Jennifer Lawrence together in a raunchy buddy
comedy this year.
Now, that pipe dream aside, there will be
plenty of major breakouts in the months to
come.
Daniel Kaluuya, for example, is bound for
the big time once his twisty thriller Get
Out drops and details start to emerge regarding
his part in Marvel's Black Panther.
Count on him to capitalize on rising interest
in his talent.
Alden Ehrenreich, likewise, is a name that
might reach household status this year thanks
to his forthcoming turn as Han Solo in the
Star Wars spinoff.
Ehrenreich has an impressive filmography under
his belt already with some small but memorable
roles, but headlining as Han is a career-maker.
Meanwhile, actress Sofia Boutella is also
poised to have a major moment this year, after
her work in the reboot of The Mummy and The
Coldest City arrives in theaters.
The latter project in particular seems promising,
as it's a Cold War spy thriller that gives
her a chance to steal scenes from some of
the industry's elite.
Just like she did in Star Trek Beyond.
"Pardon me."
"He likes that seat."
R.I.P. whitewashing
Unfortunately, this year will bring us multiple
films which will, again, highlight the need
for studios to stop whitewashing movie casts
— including The Great Wall and Ghost in
the Shell, both of which have already attracted
their share of controversy.
Marvel's Doctor Strange somehow managed to
survive its own issues on that front, at least
where the box office was concerned.
But with these new pictures in particular,
any enthusiasm seems likely to be dampened
by casting backlash.
Perhaps the conversations that result, whether
the films are ultimately successful or not,
will finally put an end to Hollywood's unfortunate
whitewashing tradition once and for all.
Fingers crossed.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!